we got Mike cernovich here
he says ask anyone inside a large
organization who is really in control
the answer is always HR Twitter's trust
and safety was HR on liver King levels
of steroids you crossed them and you're
out for being dangerous and a threat he
said that in response to this tweet from
Daniel Bostic who says either uh he says
certavich just exposed a divide between
Elon and Jack either Jack was lying all
along and is carrying on the deception
not super likely or his company was
totally hijacked by far left activists
and Lawless corporate bureaucrats very
likely let's get into it Mike cernovich
responded to a tweet from Twitter's
trust and safety saying they were
resigning he said you all belong in jail
and linked to a story from the New York
Post Twitter refused to remove child
porn because it didn't violate their
rules Elon Musk says it is a crime that
they refuse to take action on child
exploitation for years Jack Dorsey said
this is false Elon Musk responded no it
is not when Ella Irwin who now runs
trust and safety joins Twitter earlier
this year almost no one was working on
child safety she raised this with Ned
and parag but they rejected her Staffing
request I made it top priority
immediately
this is the level of corruption we have
seen in this country on Twitter for
years on social media they were posting
pictures of children in disgusting ways
and they did nothing so when we say that
Elon Musk did more than the GOP ever did
more than the FBI ever did he gets in
day one he says my top priority ending
child exploitation
it gets even worse than that there was
victims of a lot of this
CP a lot of this adult child content
that were coming to Twitter and were
saying hey uh this has happened to me of
being targeted my photos here are being
released here I was a child this is
illegal please get rid of it Twitter was
like hmm too bad we're going after uh
all the Republicans we're going after
we're gonna pan Laura oh yeah we're
gonna ban the people for their political
speech and and that right there shows
you uh the priority that they had there
as of course I was screaming about this
years ago I was like there's there's I
Isis on the platform there's people
beheading people there's there's radical
islamists recruiting on the platform and
your main priority is a satire uh
comedian are you freaking kidding me you
have so much to do and you fail us time
and time again so the Ayatollah of Iran
saying death to Israel death to America
and nothing happened with his Twitter
Chinese propaganda Chinese government
actors coming on nope nope that's fine
yeah so seeing Jack come out and then
being smacked down by Elon Musk is uh
absolutely promising because what Elon
Musk is talking about here is Criminal
if you know a crime is going on and you
don't do anything about it you're a part
of that act a lot of people get charged
for this for for being an accomplice uh
there was children coming to Twitter and
they ignored them well is absolutely
just just that should let's boil your
blood right now let's contextualize this
it's not like you know what what was the
last episode of Seinfeld they the Good
Samaritan law they get arrested it
wasn't like someone was standing on the
side of the road they saw someone
getting kidnapped and went I'm not
getting involved no no no this was
they're driving the car and they they
get an Uber and they pick someone up
who's like grabbing a woman off the
street and throwing them in the car and
like hey man I'm just a driver don't
mind me
that's what it was Twitter was
facilitating this Twitter had created a
platform allowing these people to do
these things to post these things they
were the vehicle by which this stuff was
delivered and they had an obligation to
say we can't have that illegal activity
in our bus so that they did nothing it's
not just Twitter it's everything of
course of course of course because
they're smart man look give it you got
to give it to them they control all the
social media they won these elections uh
and they control the universities like
before you were saying they control
education uh the Democrats you got to
put you got to tell them you know they
did something right all the social media
mainstream media education they control
everything and and everyone in society
so if we don't do anything about it now
like Tim says we're going down a
terrible path we built mines The Social
Network and I was an administrator for
like five years and we had to deal with
this fortunately it was a smaller amount
of people per day probably one percent
of what Twitter gets so it was still
manageable centrally we still had
centralized administratorship which is a
fault of a system you can't a
centralized planned system cannot handle
that amount of child porn that will come
on but you'd send it immediately the FBI
if you find something illegal
particularly something is child porn FBI
immediately is notified and that is it's
removed you can't even have it there in
a holding pattern because having it is
illegal so you need to immediately
reference and take it yeah it was on
Twitter servers as Twitter was meeting
with the FBI as they were ignoring the
problem you never saw the feds
investigate Twitter for this but now
they're investigating him because Elon
Musk took the company over and is
prioritizing going after child
pornography on on the damn program on on
the damn platform are you kidding me I
understand Twitter would have hired who
Clinton hired to when she cleaned the
whole rematch how did they not know you
know what I mean he's going to come in
and go through everything and expose
them all like how did they not bleach at
all I could see the argument of like is
just too much data like there's no way
we can handle this but that's like I
agree so maybe you shouldn't be in
control of it if you can't handle it
um that's not the argument they
knowingly knew it was happening they
knew the victims and they said we're
just going to keep it up what Jack said
when they said uh Twitter did nothing to
prevent this Jack said this is not true
I think what Jack it's kind of like
double speak what he's saying is no we
did some things to try and prevent it
but what elon's saying is it wasn't
prevented you may have done that wasn't
their top priority the priority was to
censor conservatives right that's what
they were getting at somebody posted a
Super Chat Murph tries I want to read
this one he says Elon we are going after
CP celebrities quote this platform just
isn't what it used to be I'm leaving you
think about that and you think it's a
joke right but then you think about
people like you know Harvey over in
Hollywood and what he was into and then
I you know I'm thinking about this these
these Twitter employees who refuse to
quit but then Elon comes and starts
cleaning stuff up and then all of a
sudden they're like oh no no no now I
have to leave and then you take a look
at books like that genderqueer where
it's got adult activities in it and
they're showing it to kids and uh you
have this school in Chicago that project
Veritas exposes where the dean talks
about how he brings people in to share
adult toys with children and explain how
to insert them and the difference
between lube and spit and you have to
wonder are we just being naive in
assuming these people don't want to
Target and Prey Upon children yes
because there's also the Balenciaga
Scandal there's also the corporate media
advocating for for child love there's
also of course politicians trying to
normalize a lot of this nonsense and
Insanity especially in California
there's also the FBI for over 30 years
that were helping Jeffrey Epstein run an
international trafficking and extortion
operation as the children and victims
were coming forward to the FBI and the
FBI said screw off so this is not a
coincidence I don't think this is an act
on top of that is Sam bankman freed no
child porn involved in the sandbag and
free thing but he had like sleeping with
like eight or nine different women that
he was working with that's not the same
thing but it's a highly sexual no no no
no no no there's a better place point in
their Ian and it's that they're not
going after him they haven't talked
about the section I mean not that
there's anything wrong with sleeping
with nine different women that work for
you I don't care but uh you could argue
about the ethics involved in that but
the the where's the where's the talk
about it like it's so underground sexual
you know but it's not I don't I don't
care about the SPF orgy stuff I care
about the SPF illegality that they're
not going after why because he aligned
with them politically there's also
there's also cuties on Netflix there's
so many examples of this just to go back
on this particular topic related to this
larger discussion that Elon Musk is
talking about I mean how more blatant do
you need it to get what what do you need
politicians ditching their secret
service and going to private islands oh
wait hold on yeah how more obvious do
you need to to make it seriously yeah
what happened with uh Menendez remember
that one yeah uh what happened with
Trump's uh what was it Transportation
secretary uh who gave him the sweetheart
deal of a lifetime you know again we
could keep going
my problem with repealing Section 230
protections for these social networks is
that someone in the FBI could put child
porn on the Twitter server and then go
arrest the CEO for holding child foreign
I hope so but I mean I think you really
do need to protect these these platforms
as egregious as it seems It's hard to
navigate under that premise Ian you're
saying that section 230 actually allows
someone to legally hold child
exploitative material it doesn't these
platforms like you were saying you can't
have it section 230 does not protect
that
okay yeah yeah this is a it's a it's a
long-term conversation about things
other than child porn as well but things
that may be deemed illegal and about
who's in trouble for having the illegal
content
the sheriff in Florida like everybody
knows him his name is Grady Judd he's
like pretty famous and they're
constantly setting up this child this
child pornography Rings you know always
online you always read about them
they're arresting so they should be
doing more stuff like that but counties
could do that you know you don't have to
leave it to the the main social media
platform if it's happening in New York
County then they can set these people up
and hold them accountable where they
should be I think it was crazy the last
time he made an arrest in Polk County uh
a lot of these people were working at
Disney you know they did a sting
operation oh yeah you remember that
Grady Judd did uh Sheriff Grady he did a
sting operation and hit and like I don't
know like 10 people were working at
Disney imagine that you know you have
your kid you strolling around and you
got one of those Mickey Mouse kids and
that routinely happens there's a lot of
news stories month after month caught at
Disney caught at Disney Disney employee
or Disney Network again again they play
a lot of people but there's also a lot
of coincidences especially with some of
their uh symbolism and some of their
child movies that is also very
disturbing and deserves a conversation
on its own so these people get a job at
Disney it's obvious right they want to
talk at kids what other place do you
think these people might try and find
employment where they can surround
themselves with children is there is
another another job like you know public
service inside of Nursery Square this
where the kids go you know what what I'm
I'm trying to elude yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh that's an interesting point oh that's
right if they're gonna go to Disneyland
or world or whatever because a lot of
kids there maybe many of these people go
to grade schools too to be surrounded by
kids there as well
oh I I well I could talk about the
school sexualization but I mean you made
a good point about the entertainment
industry you said you guys mentioned
Disney but that whole industry man it is
dirty for kids it is dangerous to get
kids into that I was there as an adult
and they were trying to sexually get me
to do porn scary you can't yeah raising
a kid these days you just can't you guys
have any of you have kids no negative if
I wouldn't I wouldn't be telling anybody
uh one day all right guys they'll have
kids and you'll see you know you just
gonna have to keep an eye on them and
private school is the answer
the world is so crazy if I would have a
kid I would never be posting photos of
it I would never tell anybody about it
because how vicious and crazy some
people are small you know yep a lot of
people will I worry all the time what my
sons you know every day I worry where
they are that's everyone and they're
adults you know just because I'm damaged
from what I went through I can't you
couldn't imagine something that happened
at The Wanted of them I would see
pictures of people with their newborn
babies but they'll put like a block the
face out a lot of people of in the last
15 years were putting the full baby face
and everything online so everyone knows
what their kid looks like beautiful baby
it's a chance for us to be like yeah
let's support the beauty of the child
and I think it Collective Consciousness
I think that it actually enhances the
beauty of humans when we can all
appreciate each other but
it also lets everyone in the world know
what your baby looks like and that's
like you were saying Luke I mean that's
that's pretty pretty wickedly terrifying
you know because I we know that
governments will go after people's kids
they'll be like you should have had a
better father it was a uh Jamal what's
his name is this khashoggi is the guy
that he was the reporter that he was the
show he's a different guy it was the kid
the 16 year old was killed by Obama on a
drone oh abdulrahman
and is the son of a terrorist you know
what they call the terrorists what was
he though he was working with the
Pentagon before when it came to
de-radicalization
so he was working with also the Intel
intelligence agency the father yes
yeah okay so yeah yeah Anwar I don't
think uh his dad committed any crimes he
was a preacher he preached to Jihad
against America I see and they said well
his speeches you know weren't I could be
wrong about that but let's just that
that's why I usually I stick to
discussing Abdul Rahman 16 year old kid
from Boulder lived in San Diego goes or
uh I think that's what it was then he
goes and flies to Yemen to visit family
and then Obama blows him up well the
father had a lot of connections to the
government and the Pentagon and then he
became radicalized and became a cleric
and then started preaching uh you know
radical Islam and then the son was
killed yeah he was killed the sun was
killed and then uh and then there's
reports of the daughter being killed uh
off of uh the first uh you know First
Command of the Trump Administration on a
Commando raid that Obama wouldn't uh
call off on but Trump allegedly called
off on that's the official version of
events it could have been an accident
could have been North Korea style family
targeted execution I don't claim to know
what's going on yeah no I think I think
the United States sent a clear message
that if you screw with us we kill your
kids I thought so too yeah I mean that's
another Vibe I'm getting and partly why
I don't want to put pictures of my kids
all over the internet I mean if you look
at the extradition and torture that the
intelligence agencies were doing
especially when it came to flying people
to Egypt
um what's his name talks about this
oh imagine the ones really talks about
this all the time sorry for butchering
your name I think I'm just dyslexic and
I'm just horrible with pronouncing names
but he talks about how you know many
times retailing people get picked up
sent to Egypt and again we can't even
discuss some of the horrible things the
torture that people have gone through
officially under the rendition flights
and the torture flights that were
conducted with your tax dollars and
including children including hurting
children in front of parents and doing
unspeakable things that you can't even
mention uh uh how do you say his name
again oh it's magic like magic yeah
magic talks about this in in detail but
it's but it's a conversation that a lot
of people aren't ready for you'll always
remember Magic's name because it's like
magic
grew up with a kid in High School's last
name was magic dude magic Nawaz is a
brilliant uh I don't know what you call
him a scholar I don't know how you
define the guy reformed terrorists I
believe yeah yeah he's a brilliant guy
he was in that prison in Egypt he
describes his his you know situation
um he's he's a brilliant uh fascinating
thinker and his content is Top Notch
right now when it comes to speaking out
against a lot of the craziness that
Society is is dealing with and now he's
helping de-radicalize a lot of people uh
which I think is absolutely critically
key and important and in many instances
doing the opposite of what the Intel
agencies are doing I think a lot of the
benefit people could get right now is is
don't worry so much about showing the
world your life I kind of went through a
phase where I was like I want to
document everything so everyone can I
can get my likes and then and also I'll
be remembered you know who doesn't want
to be remembered but it can be like less
is more sometimes I think you guys got a
good uh what you're doing you move to
rural areas I think it's great I live
all right chickens goats chicken cam you
got to do a goat cam at my place yeah
goat City we could do a goat Camp so
living rural I think is going to be the
future for a lot of families doing some
homesteading raising your own beef being
that's a way to get your family uh be
involved with them like eggs fresh air
no pollution people go tap their sink
water in the city and then they they're
like I gotta go to the grocery store to
buy my food you think it's your food you
think that's your water they can turn it
off if the grocery store doesn't have it
you don't happen you saw it with covet
you couldn't get you couldn't get a lot
of the things where I live you know I'm
hungry I'll just go out and kill a goat
or you know what I mean we got no more
chickens the dog ate all my chicken but
I have like you know 120 goats they're
great to watch they have two to three a
year you know so they're constantly
growing I don't name any of them they're
all numbered yeah Ranch you never name
anything I I heard something really
clever from uh I think it was from Kim
she's our chicken tender she said uh a
friend names their Birds after holidays
so that one's Christmas you know thanks
that one's Thanksgiving and then you
know when you eat them yeah that's
pretty cool but we don't the only thing
that has names on my Ranch is dogs how
many dogs we have three dogs two
livestock Guardian dogs and I have a
Malinois which one is the the Anatolian
[ __ ] but I couldn't knock that out I
have a German Shepherd too I raised it
on a farm and I and I made sure to teach
it I was like hey you stay away from the
chickens you respect the chickens yeah
it was tough it was because they have
that drive especially the Shepherds they
love to taste things around they love to
run around they're like we need to get
it it was it was a lot of fun I have a
Malinois that's trained to a tea like I
love them I got him when he was two
months old and he was like I training
him to not go after the chickens but
e-collar is a really good tool for
anyone that that's training the dog
seriously I have an e-collar and he it
didn't take me too long for him to keep
him off the chickens but what's pretty
interesting now is you know he's a
protection dog and he does everything
for me but now I got him hurting Tilly
he loves it man I'll go out like you
know there'll be a hundred goats out
there and he can move them you know I
got to be really quick with the button
because he says Drive will get too hard
and he could easily like just break
one's neck how much how much so how much
land do you need for a hundred goats
well I have about 750 Acres wow and we
move him it's pretty I live in this area
that uh it's it's free open range So
lately the price of hay went from like
seven dollars a bale to now 21 a bill so
a lot of times I just open my Gates and
I just say you know this is nothing's
for free here you know what I mean it's
not like in the City where you get your
food stamps and you don't have to go
work for yourself so I send the goats
like hey go out there get find something
to eat or you're not going to get you're
not going to have anything you're going
to go hungry so it's pretty interesting
I wake up in the morning I'm looking out
my Ranch I see him going out the front
my front the gate they're going down the
street like a mile and then I'm telling
you it's unbelievable they come back the
end of the day they come and back they
know where it's safe and they're such
interesting animals to watch I went to
California during the drought to
interview farmers and we went to a bunch
of dairy farms I go to one and we just
we literally just walked up to houses
knocked on doors and you know guy
answers and we were like Hey we're
reporters we're uh we wanted to get the
opinion of farmers because of the
drought because of the regulations and
he's like yeah for sure and he walks out
and he he shows us around the edge on
the side of his building and there's a
whole bunch of cows just eaten and
there's no fencing or anything they had
their their machine where the cows could
go and get milked they had the thing
where all the food was being put and I I
can't remember exactly it was probably
hay or something and I don't know what
they were eating but then I was like
there's there's no fences and he's like
yeah and I was like can they just leave
and he goes where would they go and I
was like I don't know just like randomly
walking off and going somewhere and he
was like
but where like why would they leave
their house yeah they're not going
anywhere he's like I don't need to put a
fence up I'm not worried about it he's
like there's no Predators that's like
the kid that doesn't leave his house
living in the basement he's got the
refrigerator's full he's got heat air
conditioning he's got cars now anyway
yeah the cow's got it made they don't
want to leave yeah these goats I thought
when I first got them they were like I
thought they would never come back and
it's just interesting they cut they're
creatures and they they all so they're
coming back so how one how much is how
much is like the average goat weigh
average goat I would say is about the
the mama goats probably about 130 140
pounds so how long how much food does
one goat produce oh the food probably
about 40 pounds 40 pounds or 40 pounds
of meat uh for each goat it's delicious
like I don't want to bite like I'm I'm
at the point now I got I just started to
herd of cattle too so we have about five
uh you learn a lot about the cow
business you know when living on a ranch
what a heifer is what a cow what a bowl
heifer is there's just so many cows that
you know they'll teach you something so
if a cow's pregnant you don't say
pregnant's covered or open if they're
not pregnant they're open if they're
pregnant they're covered this is what I
learned from East Coast out to Oregon
how long does that 40 pound of meat last
you got your family
uh last well we usually like I'm pretty
generous with it you know all the time
with friends and family we're always
like we gave it away or we're always
constantly eating it you know but we uh
it's really great to be able to raise
your own meat I explain it to people
it's like what's the difference between
having a garden and raising Tomatoes I'm
just raising beef right well goat you
know what you know right there that's
what life I love it man I I using the
stuff that you raise and I know what
they're eating I have no problem killing
them what about the Udders and like the
internal organs do you eat that stuff
too no no no beef liver
we gotta have a conversation about it as
a kid I used to eat liver all the time
when I was growing up but I haven't I
have my first steer now so he's about uh
700 about 600 pounds so I won't butcher
him until the fall he was born in June
but I have another five that are covered
that'll be given birth and they they
take about nine months you know to give
birth Earth a cow and a goats about five
months if you're not going to be doing
anything with the liver I'll gladly take
it off of your hands but but I would
love to have a conversation about organ
meat because there's there's a lot of
important stuff that a lot of people
don't um get especially when it comes to
a lot of the American diets
comparatively to a lot of other
International diets that do prioritize
organs because they're usually more
nutrient dense than of course makes
sense but I'm definitely not going to
let anything go to yeah you know lost
one people the saying is usually nose to
tail you know the butcher's so it's
crazy they're so busy like where we live
that you could make an appointment like
if you want to butcher a cow it could be
like seven eight months out whoa for the
butcher to come so I'm almost half to
like for the next fall soon I'll have to
make unless my neighbor I got a neighbor
that's a pretty good butcher there's a
huge shortage and it's so expensive many
people don't understand that's one of
the biggest expensive uh you know Parts
when it comes to reading it costs me if
I want one of my neighbors he'll do a
goat for me for about a hundred the the
you know you're raising these animals do
you have concerns about parasites in
them when you're eating them they no we
constantly you know that uh you know not
all the time if I see I know now from
watching when an animal's sick and we'll
treat it and once a year I'll treat them
and everybody in the herd of ivamectin
so ivamectin works great uh for the
parasites uh with goats you know you
just put a syringe you just fill it and
you you they need it you know is that
all you use I remake them yeah and well
you know with the goats is I'm fortunate
I have a lot of pasture and irrigation
so I can move them around it's when
these animals sit in like their own
pasture and they'll eat stuff down and
they get sick a lot more because they're
eating down to the ground where their
feces are yeah so I learned all you know
I went from looking at scrap metal to
looking at real estate now I look at
Goat [ __ ] on my Ranch to see if they're
sick so it's crazy you do have cows
though right yeah we have some cows how
much milk uh per day does it come oh we
don't we use a beef cows there's beef
cows there's Angus there's herefords
there's Charlize you know you'll learn
all these things oh yeah yeah we want to
get a cow and we were told no because
they produce like eight to 12 gallons
per day what what they're not telling
you is like even with the goats like if
you stop milking a goat it's like a
full-time job if they don't have a kid
on them you got a milk like twice a day
or they go through like some serious
pain yeah but I don't you're gonna get
get a beef cow you buy a steer and you
got enough Akins you put a steer on it
and you feed them or you probably have
enough feed on what you what you said
you had how many acres you got black 50.
so you got a lot of trees though oh yeah
but I don't know they'll be able to find
you want it everything right they eat
the blackberries you gotta see I'm like
in Blackberry I think they just that's
their favorite food the blackberries and
they and blackberries grow like four
feet a year if I didn't have these goats
eating I would be it would be
unbelievable the what they do to keep my
place looking nice thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time